calling
all la influencers to play metaphysics
this is precisely
why we moved
our show simulation to los angeles
to be able to take the biggest questions
around the nature of reality
the nature of consciousness and
maximizing human potential
directly into the hearts of the people
with the greatest
influence mimetically to disseminate
ideas to millions of people in their
audiences
as these celebrities and influencers
become
more awakened and enlightened themselves
they also have a massive butterfly
effect on their audiences and on the
world
this is the most efficient way to
catalyze the planetary awakening
that's why we moved our show here after
doing 700 plus
interviews on science and
entrepreneurship and spirituality
we relocated to la from silicon valley
to be able to bring these biggest
questions into
many of the people with the greatest
influence to
catalyze the awakening
and this is becoming more and more
commonplace in hollywood you just had
mike
tyson who appeared on logan paul's
podcast called impulsive
where he was promoting entheogens
entheogens
is synonymous with psychedelic
psychedelics means
mind manifesting whereas entheogens
means
unleashing god within and
its preferred word of choice
for myself and many others
mike tyson promoting that was huge
and he's had the unleashing of god
within
after undergoing all that he did
in boxing which is huge
and the mainstreaming in general
of asking the main questions
like who are we why
are we here what is our
true nature what is
i who am i
and how to maximize planetary prosperity
the main questions out of that batch
is the question what is
i because the question
what is i it directs
attention inward
what is consciousness what is awareness
is that consciousness awareness shared
among us is it also eternal
is this just one creation design is this
just one
expression of infinity one
dream that we are a part of and
we are eternally immersing ourselves
into these dream creation designs
so the question what is i
gets us to turn our attention inward
whereas the vast majority of the time
our attention is turned
outward we're not aware of awareness
itself so that's huge
and then how to maximize planetary
prosperity is also critical
because it focuses our attention on the
unique artistic expression that each one
of us are
toward architecting protocols that
maximize abundance and well-being and
prosperity
for everybody the sustainable
development goals
the basic needs being met and
actualizing the unique creative gifts of
all billion
all eight billion of us and beyond
so this is why we're here to drive these
main questions home
into the heart of the most influential
people in
los angeles in hollywood and so this is
a really exciting
for me on specifically the vlog squad
discussing the nature of reality
and i've been really excited
about what they've achieved and also
about getting these biggest questions to
them and many of these other diverse
prominent nodal clusters of people here
that are beginning to
get excited about these biggest
questions
old hollywood in many ways has no idea
what's going
on with digital quotient or dq
a lot of old hollywood was from the last
couple of decades
kind of in the multi-million dollar
sets and undergoing a process of showing
up every single day
for seven days to shoot and then doing
that
for weeks and weeks and months on end
and then having that be produced into
just one movie
that thickens released into theaters
and so if you remember vhs and dvd
stuff like that whereas
the modern new hollywood
understands dq and by dq digital
quotient i mean
generally speaking understanding
information technology
and the way that we disseminate
content mimetics memes
the cultural unit of information
transfer
and via these mediums like tick tock
snapchat instagram specifically those
platforms
are very prominent in what has evolved
to be the
vertical video format
and also the 15 to approximately 60
second
per video format which is very
interesting
and then the youtube which has been
around
much longer but is in the horizontal
format
and also has a much longer length
content where
from five minutes ten minutes up to even
podcasts
that go on for hours
also new hollywood understands the
computer generated imagery cgi
which we've learned that approximately
90 percent or so
of the newest productions are cgi
which is fascinating and also vr virtual
reality
agi artificial general intelligence
and the way that algorithms
will be playing a massive role with
machine learning
with understanding large amounts of data
and drawing out insights from that
as well as having a
more generally speaking algorithmic
society in general around
our basic daily
processes things like
avatars are becoming more popular
as well doing things like creating a
digital twin of
yourself and then having that digital
twin
go into the the digital spaces
on the interwebs across platforms and
then be able to engage with audiences
that way
and also technologies like bio and neuro
technology with things like
neura link and beyond
and so a lot of the new hollywood a lot
of the millennials
and the generation z and also
the generation alpha who are the newest
generation
that are born between 2010
and 2025
that this new hollywood era
needs a metaphysical truth as an
anchor aka a focus
for what to build around for what to
create
content around what should millennials
and generation
z and generation alpha
be focused around building well it
should be around metaphysical truth
around these biggest questions around
consciousness
around the nature of reality around how
that is
shared and that is eternal and
that love is the recognition that we
share
our eternal being and this is but one
dreamed creation design expression of
that that we're immersed into
and beautifully
as unique expressions artistically
experiencing
and so also maximizing human potential
is another critical one of those anchors
a focus for what to build around and so
these ideas like one infinite creator
expressing itself
maximizing human potential are going to
be the critical anchors
and focuses for what the
new hollywood will be building around
and what we're super excited to be a
catalyst
for
we have some audio from the podcast to
play here
a great place to start is influencers
that are already discussing these big
questions
for example the views podcast that david
dobrik and jason nash
host they have this very recent episode
that they published
called biggest life failure
and from the time stamps between
2020 and 26 36
if you would like to go and listen
this is where we will begin here
and then we will
pause as we go through the podcast
and we will review what we've been
listening to
and also i will provide feedback and
insight around the metaphysics and
around the consciousness
and that will be a good way for us to
begin
this process so let's
dive in
mike do you think the world revolves
around you i do have a slight
theory that like if you anything that's
not directly in front of me doesn't
exist so like when i don't see
my math teacher used to tell me that all
the time like if like i haven't seen you
in however long two weeks
you didn't exist until i saw you yeah
yeah and like you'll exist on the screen
if i see you like on my phone
in like a story or something on my own
you don't actually exist outside of my
own mind like nothing exists outside of
my own mind yeah
jay what do you think about that you
think that sounds crazy what the mike's
center of the universe
i mean it does sound insane when you
look at it that way like how do i know
that you guys exist when i leave totally
and it's
like and it's like we can [ __ ] sit
here and be like mike you're crazy
but like all right so
let's play off that first bit to start
so david doberg asks
mike sheffer who is a member of the vlog
squad
and who also hosts a podcast called hoot
and a half
with matt king
and mike in many ways has
you'll notice throughout this
breakdown has a pretty strong
understanding of
what we're going to be unpacking so
david asks
mike mike do you think the world
revolves around you
and mike answers anything not directly
in front of me doesn't exist
and david said my math teacher used to
tell me that all the time
and david's mentioned this before as
well
and mike says nothing exists outside my
own mind
and then mike also says how do i know
you exist when i leave this room
generally speaking these are very very
important
philosophical questions fellow sophia
means the love of wisdom and it's a
really important
question to be asking it has
a lot to do with metaphysical
idealism idealism means that
consciousness is inextricable
from reality and again metaphysics is
the study of the nature of reality
so realities require observers
just like dreams
this reality requires
us as awareness
that is shared in eternal
to be present as an observer
as a witness
in this dream creation design just
like in our dreams when we
go to sleep at night we
sleep a third of our lives and we dream
for a good portion of that as well and
when we
simulate these dreamed realities
we immerse ourselves into them
as an observer that's
going around and exploring the dream
simulated environment and experiencing
it
and that reality requires
an observer to be in it to experience it
in your dream
just like this one does that were
immersed in now
and in your dream what happens
is as soon as that dream simulation
ends and then the next
dreamed simulation begins guess what
the observer the witness the
awareness stayed the same
it is undergoing a different experience
in the second dream in the new
environment
but the awareness stayed the same that
is
the same eternal awareness the eternal
witness
or observer that is shared among all of
us
that we are talking about in the dreams
at night
just like we are talking about here in
this
dreamed creation design in this reality
these analogies are super explained like
i'm five they're super simple
these codes
that are in amnesia they're the
remembrance
that we're going under to recognize our
own true nature
it's that simple
so in the perennial
spiritual traditions usually what is
said
is that you are the sky
so your awareness that is eternal and
shared is the sky
and then all of the clouds that appear
in the sky in awareness
are like the thoughts and the objects
and the emotions and the perceptions and
the sensations
and the beliefs all of those are clouds
that appear in the eternal awareness
of the sky so when you know yourself as
the eternal awareness of the sky that's
experiencing the clouds
you know yourself as peace and happiness
experiencing all of these different
clouds
versus if you don't know yourself as the
eternal awareness of the sky
and you only know yourself as the
limited
finite clouds
of experience that are happening you're
tied up in all of those
clouds and the knots of those
experiences
and you don't know yourself that's why
2500 years ago the greeks
had the main delphic maxim written on
the top of the
temple of apollo at delphi that said
know thyself
know thyself means know thyself as
the one infinite creator as god
as an expression of that know thyself
as that and know all others as
expressions of that same
source
and as you can tell here
when
when mike was saying things like nothing
exists outside my mind
it's also important to remember that
when you get to these advanced
stages of consciousness awareness
when you get to these advanced stages of
recognizing the true nature of our being
you reach what's called an all-inclusive
awareness
so it's no longer just being aware of
your
own awareness but it's also
being aware of other people's
awareness when you're
in a conversation with somebody you no
longer are just aware
of your own awareness and you as the sky
but you're also aware of their awareness
and
them as the sky in that sky being
shared between you
they are a unique expression of that
sky and you are a unique expression of
that sky
and that's most clearly the analogy
leveraged via understanding the
iris the iris is our unique
coloration and the pupil
is the sky is the shared eternal
awareness
now that's just with two people now if
you imagine you add a third person a
fourth person
now imagine an entire stadium
that's filled with people or if you want
to go so far as to imagine an entire
country or the
whole planet all
eight billion people's awareness
at the same time holding
all of that simultaneously
being aware of everyone's awareness
simultaneously
and it's fascinating because when you
begin undergoing
the expansions of your own
awareness to get closer and closer to
the
all-inclusive awareness what happens is
interesting things like you begin
realizing that pretty much at any point
in time
there are approximately 1 billion people
around the planet that are asleep
out of the 8 billion and that's pretty
interesting
and
you also gain a greater degree of what
is called
the integral so in
calculus what happens when you
run the integral the integration is the
summation of the infinitesimal data
and so in this case you go from 0 to 8
billion
and you make a summation of all
of the awareness of the planet
and that's when you begin
really having a high level of
metaphysical truth you're holding the
in awareness of all eight billion
unique agents and then in calculus
there's also the derivative
in this case it'd be the derivation or
the differentiation
or the individuation
and so that is when you have the unique
expression the iris
the unique artistic expression of the
infinite
in each one of those eight billion
and that's why each one of us is super
beautifully
unique and is contributing a unique
gift they're actualizing a unique gift
into our beautiful dream creation design
and another way you think about that
from a perspective of biology and the
code of life which is really important
is the integration is like
the 99.9 percent genetic
similarity between humans at the level
of dna
whereas the derivation the
differentiation the individuation
is like the 0.1 genetic
difference between humans the unique
gift
so again the 99.9 similarities like the
pupil
the eternal shared awareness and then
the 0.1 percent
differentiation individuation artistic
expression is like the iris
and that's the actualization of the
unique gift
it was very much like the inward
meeting the one infinite creator
undergoing that process of god
realization
and then the outward of the creative
expression of that infinite
and then when you undergo that process
what happens is like lao tzu described
with wu way there is an effortless
action
that comes outward once you are realized
as that
because you can never commit malevolence
onto another because you recognize that
is the same self that's the same one
infinite just expressed through
a unique artistic expression
and so you channel the highest morality
the highest ethics
the highest well-being and prosperity
architectures to maximize human
potential
and this is also very much resonant with
donald hoffman's conscious agent theory
and so science is kind of like don said
on our
interview on our show science is kind of
like johnny come lately
to what spirituality has known for 5 000
years and in this case
don hoffman is doing graph dynamics with
conscious
agents and some of the ideas
are very much like what the perennial
spiritual traditions have been saying
like
for example like we play in grand theft
auto you
render only the local experience you're
rendering
only the part of the map that you're
experiencing
so there are currently other agents in
china
india russia saudi arabia brazil etc
that are rendering
sao paulo and beijing and moscow
and i'm rendering los angeles
here and so
these are important key
insights to remember that even science
and even to me it's just like
so that's an important
bit that jason brings up which is a good
question to ask
which is that how do i know i haven't
been dealing with a narcissist this
whole time
as though it would be like solipsism
where that would be narcissistic
where it would be saying that everyone
else
is an npc which stands for a non-player
character
like in a game where it's the computer
that's playing as the characters rather
than
actual agents of infinity that are
playing as those characters
and so in this case it's not
like solipsism but instead it's like our
grand theft auto games
are overlapping so in this case it's
like
the multiplayer missions
so like the views podcast for example
the gta character you can use
call of duty or halo or fortnite or any
of these games minecraft
you can use any of these games that the
david dobrik character comes to play
with the jason nash character to
play the multiplayer mission which is
the creative expression
of the views podcast and occasionally
they'll have people like
mike sheffer that come on as another
multiplayer character
in the creative expression of that
individual podcast episode that
mike would contribute to
and so
this is the simple
way for us to understand this again is
the very simple pupil
and iris analogy where each of us is the
shared infinite which is the pupil which
is the observer
just like in the dream at night that we
simulate
that we immerse ourselves as the
observer into
and then the experiencing a unique
coloration is like the iris is like the
character itself
that's why the david dober character is
having a unique
coloration then the jason nash character
then the mike scheffer character those
are having different
colorations on the iris but the pupil
itself is the shared awareness
again just super explain like i5
childlike analogies
that are really important especially to
drive home metaphysical truth
in the los angeles hollywood influencer
celebrity space
that then can butterfly effect out to
the masses around
the world especially with the generation
z and generation alpha and the digital
quotient that they have with the
dissemination
across those platforms
okay so this next bit is
awesome yeah i mean it's not like
there's an actual explanation for what
the universe is
but also can all be [ __ ] made up if i
treat other people badly because i'm the
center of universe then that means i'm
also treating myself badly so it's
better to treat the other people
quote-unquote
good because they are they're all part
of me so i should still be a good person
i've worked so there's two parts there
that are great
you just heard at the beginning there
you heard
david dobrik say that there is no
explanation
for the universe this could all be
made up i've heard david mention this
before
on his vlog as well
that is really important
this
question in itself is the
main question of metaphysics
the nature of reality and also around
philosophia
the love of wisdom it is also its main
question
which is what is the explanation
of why we're here of the universe
and when you land on that question of
what is the explanation of why we're
here of the universe and what is this
i what is this awareness
when you land at that question
and you dedicate yourself full time not
like
part time where you're just
doing it on the side for an hour a week
but when you really go hard like 40
hours a week
on the answer to this question
that's when the truth will yield because
you will have the earnestness
you will have the dedication you will
have the desire
to know yourself
and that's when the truth yields and so
i would encourage people like david here
and many others in the vlog squad and in
the hollywood space
to dedicate themselves full time to the
answering of this question
i know that david has his views podcast
that is now
in a really beautifully designed studio
space in his new house which is
awesome this super
visionary around where it's heading
which was also something that i was
excited about
hoping to see that you would do in your
next step
and that to bring on
the major guests in hollywood onto shows
like
views or like impulsive or like the
different
major podcast platforms that
have developed in hollywood and to bring
on these
guests and then ask them these biggest
questions so if one of david's main
questions became
what is your explanation for the
universe even if his guests
did not have a way to answer that and it
was just
laughing at the question at least it's
creating
the butterfly effect it's knocking over
the first domino it's watering
the seed of the metaphysical truth
inquiry
which is huge and so this is the type of
work
that i'm here to do and that simulation
is here to do
and a little bit of sanskrit will help
the majority of the awakening west
india in many ways is the most
spiritually rich nomenclature
lexicon language over the last five
thousand years
and so we'll go ahead and
bring many of these concepts to the
awakening
west to help them
so first we'll start with lila
lila means the divine play
the cosmic play and so when you ask the
question what's the explanation for the
universe
the sanskrit tradition
talks about it especially
just the indian
subcontinent in general talking about it
as though
it's a big divine play a big
cosmic play and that
it's really important to use that word
play because play
is like the child like awe
in the childlike creativity and the
child-like laughter
and those components are really
important and especially if any of you
have watched
the vlog squads vlogs and the way that
david specifically captured the content
and then edited it
and i know that joe volpis also played a
critical role in that process
and that the editing style itself is
very much
childlike it's very much like play it's
very much like highlighting the key
stories and the key
funny things that have happened and so
the more in a sense you think about the
universe
like it is a child-like
exploration and a child-like play so
that one infinite creator expressing
itself
through us and this dream creation
design
the more that you recognize that
there's an amount of peace and happiness
that comes with the recognition of
eternity
that then you bring to the dreamed
creation design you
bring peace and happiness to leela to
the divine play
rather than trying to extract peace and
happiness
from the divine play because seeking
peace and happiness
externally just like in the parable of
the prodigal son in the bible
you'll hit a breaking point the ego
always hits a breaking point whether it
be conspicuous consumption
or whether it be greed or whether it be
fame or clout or any of these external
objects that we chase and seek for
happiness and peace
we hit a breaking point just like we are
currently with planetary ecology and
geopolitical relations and technology
asymmetries and all these types of
things
where eventually we have the breaking
point and the turn
inward and then the recognizing like
rumi said
you go from room to room looking for the
diamond necklace that's already around
your neck
meaning that consciousness awareness is
the nature of it is peace and happiness
so you recognize your eternal shared
awareness
and that is the diamond necklace around
your neck that's refracting
the unique
expression of the source light through
it as an artistic expression in
the actualization of a gift in the
stream creation design
and that by recognizing that process you
bring
peace and happiness to the creation
design rather than trying to extract
from it
and that's typically why the word maya
which is another very important sanskrit
word that was initially
the theory of it was formulated by adi
shankara
about 1300 or so years ago and he's one
of the most important
philosophers that's ever lived and he
was also
massively involved in advaitha which
we'll get to in a moment
maya means the intoxication so meaning
that
when you go out seeking peace and
happiness externally
there's an intoxication that happens
because you think that you can actually
get
peace and happiness externally but you
can't awareness and consciousness
is what is eternally nature
of peace and happiness
and so it's to recognize that and then
recognizing that
in maya in what changes so in this case
maya changes these creation designs
change just like in your dream when you
dream at night
the the landscape
that you dreamed that you've immersed
yourself into changes
but when that dream landscape ends in
the next dream landscape begins
when you leave the eiffel tower in paris
and you go to the
great wall of china and you're now on
the great wall of china
the dream landscape has changed but the
observer has stayed the same
and so it's very similar with maya in
these dream creations is that
you recognize that you're the eternal
shared observer that is experiencing
the different creation designs the
different fluctuations
energetically which we'll get to here in
a bit at the quantum mechanical level
that are then creating the
appearance of form and matter
and so to be
intoxicated by the form and the matter
and to think that you're gonna find
peace and happiness there is a mistake
that's been known for over again two
thousand years like in this parable of
prodigal son where you turn
inward and you recognize that eternal
peace and happiness and then you bring
that to all of the appearance of form
and enjoy that butterfly effect of peace
and happiness to your family your
friends your community
the world and then advaita
which literally means not
to so not to meaning non-duality
it means that consciousness and god are
one
so just like in the bible john 10 30 it
says i
and my father are one
or in sanskrit it's also meaning you
are that so you your consciousness your
awareness
is that is the ultimate it is the
supreme it is brahman
atman and brahman are one consciousness
and god
are one
and then in the next bit mike shaffer
says
it's better to treat other people well
because they're all part of me
and that's precise because the other is
the same
infinite shared eternal observer
witness but adjust a different unique
expression that is then
interacting with itself so if you
remember like we were talking about
earlier can you be
meta enough when you're in a
conversation with somebody to recognize
yourself
as the awareness the sky and
them as the awareness in the sky and
then the communication of the thoughts
emotions feelings perceptions
sensations beliefs as the clouds that
are happening in the sky
and that the sky itself is shared
and it's eternal and that's only 32
and then now try and do it with up to 8
billion
and beyond
so it's all one body it's all one shared
being and love is the recognition
that we share our being and that's what
eradicates
malevolence because you would never hurt
yourself
so it may be that egoic levels of
consciousness that are in the greatest
positions of power
the united nations general assembly the
fortune 500 ceos the 2
200 billionaires around the planet the
225 000 ultra high net worth individuals
and families on the planet the 535
people in the united states congress etc
if their levels of consciousness are
egoic
and if they are not enlightened that is
likely our
most upstream issue that this dreamed
creation design
faces and so it's most important for us
to not only bring these biggest
questions around conscious metaphysics
and maximizing potential to los
angeles and hollywood but also to these
greatest
billionaires and fortune 500 ceos etc
around the planet
because they themselves awakening
will catalyze the greatest butterfly
effects as well
okay let's go onward
i wonder if mike's so confident mike's
made his own laws
they're working no but i mean i
understand the concept of like
my math teacher used to say that all the
time they're like he's like there's a
hallway behind me but really is there
if i'm not looking at it is there
anything behind me
and i was like i have no [ __ ] idea
well this is like an actual science
quantum crucial physics where they will
do experiments and like super super
super tiny
particles that are in two places
until they are observed they're in two
different places at the same time
and then the second they look at it it
collapses into one of those two places
meaning everything doesn't actually
exist until you look at it
and that is like exactly what this
theory is i don't believe when i leave
here
you guys all shut down like robot all
right so
that part is really critical obviously
because that's what i was mentioning
earlier when i was saying things like
mike sheffer
has one of the more clear understandings
that i've been able to analyze so far
across these different nodal clusters of
leaders out here in los angeles where he
actually recognizes that quantum physics
proves observer dependence
and that's why i wrote right below that
ding ding ding this is the synthesis of
science and spirituality
spirituality knew consciousness was the
ultimate for five thousand years
and science like don hoffman says is
johnny come lately
in the last century with quantum
mechanics proving this
which is still fantastic that it has but
it's very much
johnny come lately and that
it's important for us to recognize at
a level of similarly like with quantum
mechanics
all of the infinite endless combinations
of the underlying energy fluctuations
that are possible that then
create the appearance of matter and form
is very similar to like in music
in musical notes there is
all of the infinite endless combinations
of
notes that can turn into songs
that then we as the symphony
of eternal awareness then
experience so the
analogy of quantum mechanics can be also
brought to music
and it can also be brought to art how
many different
colors can you paint on
a canvas how many different combinations
and arrangements of those different
colors can you put on a canvas
well this creation design this
civilization orbiting this star
on this planet earth that has evolved
exactly the with the story that it has
is but
one combination of that beautiful
painting on a canvas or of that
song in the symphony or of that
underlying quantum mechanical energetic
modulation that is then creating the
appearance of the form
of matter it's really critical
to make these childlike analogies with
art and with music and to tie that into
consciousness and even physics
and this is why also sir roger penrose
who won the nobel prize in physics in
2020 he has
a cyclic cosmology so
even the oroboros that is millennia
old which is literally the snake eating
its own tail
right the cyclicity the eternity
the never seizing the end of exploration
you can never
come to the end of something that is
unbounded
just like in a game when you have a
bounded map
imagine if that map was unbounded you
would never
be able to finish exploring it
that's why this planet this rock that's
why
it has a bounding function of gravity to
the rock
that's why it's so difficult to be able
to go and leave the rock and explore
anything else because the bounding
function is exactly what creates the
conscious
agents to have to undergo the forcing
function of
interacting with one another and
undergoing the process
of understanding their own nature
and we've had several people from open
ai on the show that have done things
like neural mmo where they've actually
went through the simulations
of the bounding functions and so if it's
unbounded like infinity is
unbounded you can never come to the end
of all of the combinations of dreams
creation designs or of all the different
combinations of music
that then we as a symphony will play
never reaching the end of dreaming all
the possible music combinations
and so the pupil is the single shared
observer from the big bang the pupil
the single shared observer and the iris
is the unique individuation of each
character's experience so
each one of us has a unique individuated
character experience that's the iris and
the shared eternal
observer is the pupil
okay david david just goes bye jay
how do you know that he's actually doing
stuff when you're not seeing him
yeah like how do you don't have proof of
any of this how do you know that your
kids are
stories but how do you know that your
kids are at your house instagram is
what's proven reality for you
but like how do you know like how do you
know that there is a past
i just know man that's my reality i i'm
firmly gripped in reality i've been
around a long time
i understand have you ever done
i'm looking forward to also helping
with people like jason because in this
case
you know being around for a while and
saying things like i'm firmly gripped in
reality
a lot of the older consciousness
especially of
my parents and our parents
around our millennial or gen z age group
that the we'll get to this
neuroscientifically
in a little bit when we talk about
things like the default mode network
but basically the conceptual schemas for
them
they're like old horses that it's much
more difficult for them to learn new
tricks and especially if these old
horses
have spent a vast majority of their life
in a sense working
nine to five and they've never even
picked up something like the doubted
ching
of laotsa and have read it
and so if you've never went to a
meditation retreat if you've never
investigated awareness itself directly
atma vichra self-inquiry
of ramana maharshi if you haven't under
gone that process
or any of these aphorisms or retreats or
entheogens
you're very much constrained
conceptually to your limited world view
and you're very usually
difficult to crack and so
it's exciting to play around with that
space and to see how really good
questions especially from
third parties outside of the normal
family and friend bubbles can insert
good questions that then help
with these profound realizations so
in this case i would like to point out
how
time itself is an illusion
when you look at these symbols
what you recognize is that a couple
thousand years ago what we decided was
that
the earth
it rotates on its axis
as it orbits the sun
once a year and it rotates on its axis
every day
and as it does that rotation on its axis
is that we wanted to be able to
create squiggly lines that would then
represent symbols that we could then put
on
sun dials and eventually clocks
like this so that we could use
time usefully to say
hey meet me at 3 p.m tomorrow at this
location
and you could easily meet somebody there
because you had this great tool of time
but time itself is an illusion time is a
hallucination that is shared
that we created in order to have that
nice
useful thing so when you
take time completely out of the equation
what happens is you
experience eternity which is our true
nature
what was before the big bang what is
going to be after
where we go that that is what eternity
is that's where we've been that's where
we're going to keep going we're just
going to keep exploring the unbounded
possibility space of different
combinations of music
and we're going to keep making these
little squiggly lines
that are different each time to try and
describe
what the process
of making it easier for us to meet
up that's what this
is and so that's why i got this
basically i'm i'm beginning to just
bring this around with me
everywhere i go and i'm just pulling
this out and beginning to have
conversation with people
about how much of an illusion it is
because
time time and ego
are the two largest anchors
that hold people back from recognizing
themselves
as infinity expressing itself
and so when we can
remove or dissolve the anchor of
ego and remove or dissolve the anchor of
time
it helps people recognize themselves as
infinity expressing itself
but it's not that you no longer ever
respond to your name anymore you do
still of course respond to your name
when somebody says
hey atlas will you bring me the
microphone you will go and bring them
the microphone
you will you won't say i only i am
infinity
and same thing with time is that when
somebody says meet me at three you will
meet them at three but then you may ask
them the question hey do you know
about time being an illusion how do you
feel about that
and so
you now carry infinity and eternity
with you as your true nature and you
bring that peace and happiness
and that knowledge that gnosis as the
greeks would say
or as this nanya or as the veda
as the russians or as the indians would
say
and as that intelligence you bring that
with you
and you create a more harmonic
metaphysical truthful enlightened
civilization
all right and so this is great we're
about to jump into
where mike was asking
jason if he has ever done psychedelics
thank you so much you ever done
psychedelics yeah yeah he says he did
dmt once and it changed his life forever
or changed your personality what did you
do i did acid and it changed your
personality forever
yeah what does that mean it just made me
a loser
made me what did you do when you were
six
david the world's worst therapist
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding no
seriously go ahead go back i didn't mean
to call you a loser
you want lollipop guys sorry everybody
when did you do ass okay
no okay when did you do i did acid when
i was 20 and then
my mic i noticed maybe like a couple
weeks later
my personality completely changed and
that was the first time you did acid oh
yeah you we talked about this right
say likes and dislikes you didn't care
about sports at all you're like you're
you're page different engagement
my engagement if you ask the kids you'll
fall off the floor
oh okay okay so what what what happened
with the acid i just was
i was really into sports really into it
like the way the way like sports guys
are into sports they're like oh you're
gonna watch the game and oh i think he
had a 300 bettinger know all the stats
no who's on who's that
like and if i and i would like yell at
the screen like i'd be like no
like one of those guys wow and then and
and i did acid and then i picked up the
sports page one day like because it's my
habit to read the sports page
every morning and i was like drinking my
coffee and i was like
looking at it and i was like i don't
care about
[ __ ] any of this bro
you know what's crazy that's not just
your sports
that's like your entire persona
so there mike shaffer asks jason nash
have you ever done psychedelics
and jason says he did lsd when he was 20
and that his personality and likes
completely changed
it's a very common thing for that to
happen
he says i went from being really into
sports to not caring about it at all
and it's very interesting because that's
again a very common thing that happened
to me and many other people
where the likes change
and they go a lot from things that you
could say are a little bit more
vapid or around the
transient or around the world of
objects and forms and
especially surface level things like
sports and
weather and stuff like that
and it changes drastically towards
consciousness towards the nature of
reality towards
becoming more in awe about nature
becoming more interested in neuroscience
becoming more interested in entheogens
becoming more interested
in how to maximize human potential and
so we'll talk about that in a bit but
that's a very profound and very common
shift that happens from anthogens super
important
and again entheogen means unleashing god
within
and that means recognizing our true
metaphysical nature
unleashing god within means recognizing
yourself as the shared eternal observer
that is infinitely being colored by
experience in these dreamed creation
designs
what like you don't care about any of
stuff things like that
yeah like any statistics any awards any
like you don't care about any of that
[ __ ] no like you don't care about
yeah that's so weird that's your entire
personality i'm not um
i don't know passionate fun
like you you don't you don't like caring
about like sports either
yes but it wasn't after a drug fueled
weekend
in the cabin in boston but but you don't
care about like i don't know how to
explain it like
things that people get excited about
like you'll be like yeah and who cares
and who cares and and who like normally
you'd be like and who cares if there's
if there's an alien landing tomorrow i'm
dead anyway
who cares well that's just because i'm
fifth do you think it was for the better
it's like a
um and that was ella i don't think so i
probably would have been happier
i feel like it's made you more
pessimistic yeah probably more
prosperous but i don't know if that's
the acid
that's just life beating at you for 45
years yeah i mean i can't say that for
sure
i heard one person say uh i went on a
shroom trip and then i never came back
oh yeah and that to me is like damn
that's deep yeah i think
no you sure with shrooms because i have
a same friend who happened with acid
like two years ago and like
he was like in our friend group and then
he just like completely cut all of us
off and he like completely changed
like his whole personality changed too
like everyone was like yeah i don't know
what happened to him he's really weird
he took acid and then like he never came
back did he die
i had a friend took acid he's a shark
now so
this is again very very normal
is the quote never came back and
it's because when people
undergo the entheogenic awakening what
happens is that they become
less gravitated towards the intoxication
of maya
of the illusion of the dreamed creation
design they're no longer pursuing
happiness and peace externally
but rather they've turned inward and so
usually what happens is you can think
about it like a bunch of unnecessary
suffering and egoic pyrotechnics
my friend dj david johnson helped me
with that one it's fascinating because
the egoic levels of consciousness will
be undergoing this very pyrotechnical
dialectics where they'll be kind of
enraging or angering
one another and creating all this
unnecessary suffering
whereas enlightened beings that are
peaceful and harmonic and happy
undergo none of that and so you really
distance yourself from that with these
enlightened realizations and it triggers
the search for metaphysical truth
and so changing friend groups to more
enlightened higher vibration beings is
very common also changing taste slash
preferences to being more in
awe by nature health consciousness
also being more artistic
being less consumerism driven and more
scientific around neuroscience and
entheogens also more spiritual around
metaphysics
consciousness union or yoga yoga in
sanskrit means union
which means the same thing as mysticism
or henosis it means union with god or
union with the absolute
so it's that turn inward and also more
spiritual around infinity
and you become also when you undergo
these antigenic awakenings you become
more driven to solve the sustainable
development goals the sdgs to maximize
human potential to awaken
others
not like in the ocean and he hunts like
little fish
dave open your mouth what's in there
it's me
i have a tiny fish in my mouth why do i
see all these tick tocks about micro
dosing
what does that mean it's like people
will taste shrimp take mushrooms sorry i
know what that means but why are you
seeing tic tocs why are you on mushroom
tiktok
i don't know you ever thought about
taking acid again and maybe it'll make
you maybe it'll
set you back make me into the celtics
again
so there was the
question about why do i see all these
tick tocks about micro dosing and david
says why are you on mushroom tick tock
and so
one of the important things to
understand is that anthogens
are literally planetary secretions you
have
the beautiful
5mu dmd from the buffalo various
toad from the glands that's secreted and
then dried on the glass sheets and then
smoked and inhaled and that undergoes
the most
rapid ego dissolution into infinitude
and then you have ayahuasca
and you have ibogaine and iboga
and of course psilocybin and magic
mushrooms
and you have all of these
the new synthesis of things like what
albert hoffman discovered with
lsd and with what we have with
mdma and the
sort of incredible
recognition that these planetary
secretions
and what we've synthesized have these
healing and awakening potentials that
have been basically criminalized due to
the perverse
incentives of things like the medical
industrial complex where you have big
pharma
that is constantly trying to choke out
these things
and when you have the perverse
incentives of physicians that don't have
an inclusive stake in their patient's
life outcome but are rather getting
compensated by big pharma to prescribe
things
that are actually addictions especially
around
opiates or like the sackler family in
purdue pharma
or in other cases around things
like
where you have to take big pharma for
things like
anxiety whereas if you undergo
psilocybin you can not only have it
be something that of the majority of
people call one of the most profound
experiences of their life but also you
don't
no longer feel anxious you no longer
feel depressed
so you have people like maps the
multidisciplinary association for
psychedelic studies that were granted
fda
breakthrough therapy designation
for leveraging mdma and psilocybin and a
bunch of other
entheogens for depression for ptsd for
addiction for
therapy for couples therapy for
end-of-life therapy for a bunch
of incredible healing and awakening
processes so anthogens are a big deal
and that's why you're seeing
a lot of it on these different social
platforms including a lot of what
i'm even making right now for our
content and another reason why is
because silicon valley
microdoses for dissolving the default
mode network dmn
and what you see is that it
takes what is normally this very
constrained conceptual world view
and it loosens it to the degree of which
you can have these novel creative
connections that form between neural
networks that were normally not talking
to each other
and i've been making a good amount of
content across all of these different
aspects on tick tock and so that's
another big thing is sort of the
recognition that you can actually be
more creative around it as well with the
dissolution on a neuroscientific level
and the maximization of creative
connections and so
that's the that's the raptors
wake up wake up hold on steph curry's
about two to three i'll call you back
you wake up you're like i'm like what's
changed and you're like i love
the boston celtics
that's the wrap there so i got those
time stamps there for you
uh at the top again which i'll go over
here in a moment but in general the
mission
again to summarize is to drive more los
angeles influencers toward consciousness
metaphysics and maximizing human
potential
civilization needs more awakened
leadership especially those with the
biggest
audiences able to inspire millions of
people to ask themselves these biggest
questions
accelerating the elevation of planetary
consciousness
more harmony love light wisdom
grace prosperity and play
for all and that really simple analogy
again
of the pupil the pupil is the eternal
shared awareness and then the
artistic palette is the unique creative
expression of the infinite which is our
iris
and that that is eternally happening
across all of these creation designs
that we're dreaming
just like we do when we go to sleep
and simulate dreams
and so again it's so critical to get not
only
we're blessed to have this bit from the
vlog squad from
views the podcast where we had a good
piece of content with david dobrik jason
nash mike sheffer
talking about this and even elopria as
well and
it's great because they are
a powerful nodal cluster in los
angeles that will
definitely be able to leverage a lot of
the awakening and enlightenment and
butterfly effect that
and many of these other nodal clusters
as well is where we're targeting
and just driving the awakening
via these people that have such a great
reach
to maximize human potential
and yeah that was a lot of fun
i'm glad we were able to
sort of
share the
exploration with an actual nodal cluster
that's doing it themselves and then
provide commentary over that which was
really interesting again it's the views
podcast with david dobrik and jason nash
episode was biggest life failure and the
time stamps were 20 20 to 26
36 and
that's all ask yourselves the question
what
is i is that i eternal is that i
shared and is that i a
unique expression of the infinite that
is
being creatively expressed eternally in
these dreams
simulations and to
have a global
both micro level conversation with your
friends your families
co-workers but also on a macro level as
a planet to awaken and to enlighten to
that
and to recognize how to maximize
planetary prosperity
and to drive that home through los
angeles through
metaphysics through consciousness
through entheogens through all these
great tools
that we have and i adore you thank you
so much for tuning in
if the video brought you value give it a
like if you haven't yet subscribe to the
channel
leave me some of your thoughts in the
comments below would love to hear from
you about how this resonated
share this with other people that you
know this would resonate with and make a
profound impact on
let's get more people thinking about how
to accelerate the planetary awakening
leveraging these hacks like getting into
many of the hearts of
people with great influence like here in
los angeles
and even lots of the high net worth
people and fortune 500 ceos around the
world we need to get
the levels of consciousness from ego to
enlighten levels
to maximize our prosperity
and that's all adore you so
so much you can join the channel if
you'd like
and gain great perks we funnel all of
the revenue back into our projects
just infinite love here we are on the
big
creative expression of the infinite and
i love being the channel literally
and having this channel simulation to
share with you
so adore you all thank you very much
infinite love thank you
you